todos los sondeos de opinión y
dedicación de votos dan desde principios
de marzo una considerable ventaja para
el candidato rodrigo chávez no obstante
los sondeos publicados en esta última
semana
muestran un casi empate técnico según la
última encuesta de la universidad de
costa rica estamos hablando de un 41% a
favor de los intereses de las personas
que se dicen completamente seguras de ir
a votar
a favor del doctor chávez un 41% y un
38% a favor del ingeniero josé maría
figueres de modo que se vislumbra una
jornada muy intensa hubo un resultado no
solamente impredecible digamos que al
día de hoy sino también con una gran
incertidumbre con respecto a quién
resultará ganador
si los escándalos de acoso sexual de
chávez han afectado a su campaña o no
han tenido gran peso para los
costarricenses
de lo que se observa en esos mismos
estudios de opinión de cultura política
notamos que en efecto esos
cuestionamientos sobre los presuntos
ilícitos o irregularidades
cuando era funcionario el señor chávez
en un organismo financiero internacional
pues ha calado de algún modo la manera
negativa en las percepciones favorables
que antes de la primera ronda se tenía
de él y aunque no ha crecido el apoyo de
manera considerable a favor de
ingenieros e maría figueres olsen pues
sí ha provocado que el crecimiento de el
señor chávez sea menor o que haya
decrecido justamente en función de esas
noticias y de esas discusiones el debate
y durante esta campaña se ha hablado
mucho de la crisis social política y
económica en el país es este un debate
que plantea un problema para figueres en
tanto expresidente del país
realmente porque ha sido uno de los ejes
discursivos parte de la narrativa
fundamental del candidato chávez ha sido
recordar
reiteradamente la supuesta pésima
gestión que desarrolló el ex presidente
figueres durante el período
1994-1998 situación que se le indica en
gran parte la situación actual a las
arcas épocas del bipartidismo en el que
liberación nacional fue partícipe
también como cabeza